I think I can solve school shootings I'm
not a gun guy but I know people love
their guns and it's America people want
to buy a gun but I think if a high
school kid buys a semi-automatic weapon
that should be like a big deal that
should be public let's make that like an
event like a wedding you got to send out
invitations get all your friends and
family the gun shop the gun shop owner
he's like the priest he holds up the gun
he goes if anyone has any objections
Speak
now or this guy will forever own this
piece okay and now we get some feedback
now I got to go hey look I'm a Uncle I
don't think you should have that gun cuz
he was molested and I know that cuz I
did
it probably a bad
idea and I think half of these shooter
kids just incel virgin weirdos they just
need to get laid but it's actually hard
to get laid in America now is to buy a
gun you can buy a gun at Walmart you
don't want to [__] anybody at Walmart
right that's why every gun shop should
double as a whouse now some Angry Kid
comes in he's like I need an AR-15 we're
like whoa whoa how about a Brazilian
18 then some kid has sex with her he
goes back to school he's like what the
[__] was I so angry about holy hell life
is good